Hello Everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome to Freddy Fazbear's Pizzaria Simulator.
[BEEP]
I hate everything about this!
Recording: Document results.
Okay, Alright.
No! I'm looking at you Baby!
Recording: Begin audio prompt in 3- *Audio cassette clicks*
Oh fuck...
Baby: 2...
NO!!!
Baby: 1...
HOW ABOUT NOT?
Hi! That's a yes. Okay.
Lemme check my BOOOOX. [BEEP]
Let's play test this bad boy! *Cheery music* Oooh. "Press space..."
UH! Shit! *Death* *Mark laughs at Helpy's suffering* [BEEP]
GET THOSE TOILETS UNCLOGGED! Somebody ate too many exotic butters over in there!
If we never get these toilets unclogged, WE'RE NEVER GOING TO GET OUT OF HERE ALIVE! [BEEP]
*Mark wines like the baby he is* I just thought it was gonna be fun and happy! [BEEP]
LEFTY! *Giggling* Lefty is FIVE DOLLARS!
You guys seeing this shit?! Lefty's five dollars!
*Chuckles* P-Pickles?
Aw why is it unavailable?
Why is my jar of pickles unavailable?!
[BEEP]
The gang's all here!
We got: Pigster, Ned Fred,
Mr Hippo and Tiny Crate Cranblem! (Tiny Crate what now?)
[BEEP]
Oooh!
Hey. Welcome to the party!
*Baby jumpscare, Mark screams*
Oh C'mon!
Baby: You should've known I'd find you...
I shouldn't have know SHIT! You just snuck up on me you piece of POO!
[BEEP]
Uh! AH AH AAAAAAAAH! YES! *Victory music*
I'm still good at this game!
*Back that A$$ up starts but slowly distorts*
Hey! Guess what? We're going on tour again! Time to beat
the dust out of these raggady bones! We're gonna be going to
St Lewis, Kensas City,
*Top 10 Anime Moves*
Denver, Lake city. We're gonna be shooting
a DVD special in Las Vegas. Los Angeles, Phoenix
San Diego, San Fransisco, Seattle *Crash*
Seattle again,
Portland,
And not only that, we're going to Europe too! We're going to the Netherlands,
Brrr!
Paris, Amsterdam. Amsterdam again!
Sorry! Mom's gonna kill me. Uk 5 times. Lots of cities. Denmark,
Germany 3 times, Norway!
Sweden! Go to TOUR.MARKIPLIER.COM to get a ticket right now or
look in the description below. Every city is listed down there. And if you don't get it
We're never gonna be going on tour again! So your gonna miss it!
So if you haven't got a ticket already go for it!
Ask your parents if you can go. Get them to buy a ticket for you.
It's not too late for a Christmas Present!
Check it out! In the description. Okay. Alright. See ya!
Bye People!
*Back that A$$ up*
Rip Canadians :'( (i know that feeling, bro.)